[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan yeah we've got a
guest today you do have a guest today
this is weird if we didn't I'm gonna say
this is my favorite guest of all time
really it's my uncle
because you got blood in the game it's
my uncle
but not as just my uncle this is a this
is a guy who um
is such a success story but talk about
starting from nothing
I mean talk about you know going to
Vietnam and trying to
train dogs in Long Island and making no
money and going to like Nathan's Hot
Dogs to do like a
he was just
you know Blue Collar came from Blue
Collar my grandparent well my
grandmother did really well but my
grandfather you know he owned like you
know different auto shops and worked on
cars and but my uncle turned in you know
a profession that really didn't exist
into something very um
what's the word successful yeah uh you
know he had his own talk show in wor
radio for 25 years he was a regular
every week for Regis and Kathie Lee he
brought animals in he trained
Letterman's dog Pacino's dog he trained
Rodney danger hey hey Warren I need my
dog train I got no respect he humps my
leg with his eyes closed you know um
just
a great story author has written many
books on animals so informative such an
advocate for animals in general
uh just a good heart can't go anywhere
if he sees a dog or an animal or
something hurting or in in Jeopardy he
has to stop he has to do something
that's in his nature he's always done
that and he he taught me a lot about
that
so I think it's kind of ingrained in me
now
um
and uh he just helps so many different
you know rescues and I'm on the board
for his hugs and kisses so if you need
some really cool treats that are
vitamins hugs and kisses Foundation
um just an incredible story I can't wait
for you guys to hear it just a few uh
Little Things uh make sure you subscribe
of course if you like this podcast and
uh you know all that stuff patreon.com
inside of you if you want to support the
podcast and give back and keep it on the
air
um the inside of you online store we
have a bunch of cool stuff new inside of
you Michael rosemum figures they only
made like nine of these or something but
they're really cool and they're like me
with little glasses and they made you
know anyway they're cute
and uh I'll be at some cons coming up uh
Philly June 2nd unless this air is after
I don't think it does yeah it might
first week of June is Philly then I'm in
Niagara Falls and then there's more to
come and that's really it I'm on the
Cameo like you know I got patreon a lot
of good things coming out
um my book I have a book I'm not going
to tell you what the book is but it
looks like it's going to be made we're
working with a publisher and we're uh
you know we're working on the deal
and then me and John heater are doing a
little show it's uh can't really talk
about that but it's uh it's gonna be fun
and uh we're working on the deal so
hopefully everything goes through
and uh but love the podcast I'm gonna
continue to do it if you love the
podcast Ryan what are the handles oh
inside of you pod on Twitter outside of
your podcast on Instagram Facebook that
is correct and um there's not really
anything else I can say oh the band
sunspin The album's out sunspit
sunspin.com please support the band if
you can
trying to get the music out there the
new album is out everywhere streaming or
get merch at sunsman.com
okay without further Ado let's get
inside
of my dear uncle
slash
uh amazing talent and
humanitarian
um you're gonna really like this one I
hope you do it's great let's get inside
of Warren Eckstein it's my partner of
you
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience uh this is a very special
episode uh you know I normally don't
have my family
on the podcast but I happen to have
someone in my family who's famous
someone who's been in the business for a
long long time and many of you may not
have heard of him
and what's amazing is he's had a very
prolific career I mean how many books
have you written eleven eleven books on
animals 11 books yeah 11 books in six
countries I mean you got a dog a book
called yes dog that's right pet aerobics
how to solve your pet's behavior
problems understanding your pet how to
get your cat to do what you want the
Illustrated cat's life Memoirs of a pet
therapist so it look it's a lot of
awesome stuff we're gonna get into it I
mean
you know you were you were one of my
role models I mean I remember being a
kid and going oh my gosh she's on we are
on wo he's a WR radio he's got his own
talk show he's on Regis and Kathy Lee
every week maybe he brings animals in he
trained Letterman's dog in Al Pacino and
Rodney Dangerfield and he but I knew all
that but as a kid you don't really ask
but how'd you do it how'd you start
doing that and it's it's such an
interesting career and probably I mean
we're a lot of people doing this when
you were young I was it Michael I was it
when I came back from overseas I
couldn't find the job how do you find
the job is that pet psychologist doesn't
exist no one was doing it so I took a
job at a dry cleaner
people would come in with dog yeah cat
hair on their clothes and they'd start
talking to me I said well if you catch
peeing in here let's do this if you
throw something in your leg do this and
I said to my I said to fame my wife at
that time I said hey you know there's a
need for my knowledge I gotta get it out
there but how did you know that you had
this knowledge I've been working with
dogs in Europe in Southeast Asia oh so
you were doing that stuff like sort of
before you came back yeah when I when I
even in Europe when I was out of the
service in Europe I spent a lot of time
there working at the big candles doing
really Advanced type training but when I
came you know I said I said to fast I
said listen I have the knowledge man but
how do I get it out to the public so I
took an ad in the Pennysaver and an
affluent Jewish area on Long Island the
five towns Cedarhurst this is what the
ad said it's on my desk to this day
we'll teach your dog Yiddish for 15 that
was my ad now that might sound funny the
funny part was people started calling me
like this guy's funny I gotta see what's
up with this guy yeah what I did is for
fifteen dollars I would go if you like
Cujo I would come to your house and
resolve any issues you had for 15 18
bucks that's how it started really
that's all how it's so you're working in
a dry cleaners and people are going yeah
yeah I got this stain it's like you know
your dog wouldn't pee if you you just
started answering questions the next
thing you know you know I've got this
knowledge you put an ad in and then it
starts to hit and you're thinking
something's going on here yeah and then
I said to my parents I said you know I'm
gonna your grandparents I said I'm you
know I'm going to be America's first pet
psychologist and the first thing your
grandmother said to me we better get him
at the therapy real quick that's the
first thing you said of course even even
years later just before she passed away
she got me what do you do for a living
you never got it yeah because I try to
explain to my friends too I'm like well
he's like you know a dog trainer he was
a dog trainer but then it turned into
you know his knowledge turned into books
and it turns into radio shows and talk
shows and people wanting this
information and
I mean did you really think when you
Faye your first wife you're you know she
loved Faye and we'll talk about that how
you know her passing how much that
affected you later in life and you know
she but she was your you know I mean for
your partner in crime you know she she
co-wrote on the books right yeah who
else was going to be with me you know
when we got married she was 18 years old
I was just out of his Service uh Gonna
Leave the dry cleaning you're gonna do
why you're gonna train how are you gonna
eat yeah seriously that's what I was
going to ask and it was rare literally
we would go
we would go to the to the supermarket I
adopted a dog uh took a dog away from
somebody because it was being abused and
we'd go to the supermarket and we'd shop
for the dog food first and if we had
money left over we'd get something for
ours seriously I'm this is not no I
believe this because yeah because you
and I want you to continue but I I
noticed you I am this isn't a a stab
this isn't a jab this isn't a but you
have always been someone who loves
animals more than people I mean for the
most part if anyone should understand it
Michael issue let me give you a prime
example you know where I grew up
Oceanside Long Island all of our
relatives lived in the Bronx they lived
here so every weekend they'd all come
out like gerbils to our house on Long
Island one be out there my uncle be out
there washing his car this one would be
doing that so all these people were
hanging out at the house I couldn't deal
with it you know how neurotic our family
was so what I did is behind my mother's
house there was a creek
right yeah in that Creek there were
muskrats there were types of ducks and
all kinds of animals so when all these
people come over I couldn't take it my
head was exploding I would go into that
yard and I would sit there and talk to
the animals there and that's what
comforted me and I knew right then and
there this was my passion that young
absolutely absolutely and so you're
you're your parents are like okay he
wants to be a an animal psychologist I
don't even know what had to go to school
for this do you like I mean what was I
mean besides just you just training
animals and like learning that whole
thing you did it on your own it wasn't
something someone can teach you right no
but I spent a little time at the
University of Frankfurt when I was over
there you know drinking some beer
steinhager and learning about animals so
I spent a lot of time and I learned an
awful lot from the uh uh from the
European trainers I learned not to do
what they did they were all like the
Gestapo my dog has to listen to me 100
of the time I said how boring is that I
want my dog to look up and say hey
Warren you talking to me I need a dog
with attitude so the bottom line is
that's what I did my training hugs and
kisses is my whole approach is is loving
them hugging them kissing them and and
you don't train them to do things they
don't want to do well how did it start
what was the first I remember you told
me there's something in the story about
Nathan's Hot Dogs in Long Island you had
this event or something yeah I I just I
don't know why it happened but I got a
call from Nathan's name Nathan's
roadside arrest on Long Island and they
had an Old Stage in the back that they
never used they said listen we're going
to fill that stage up so they hired some
guy who did a karate demonstration
before me and then they said well we
want you to come in and do something
with pets so I did a fashion show I grew
up in this town my friend showed up here
I was when I thought Macho in high
school doing a fashion show with
schnoodles poodles and wearing tutus and
I never probably got off my I got off
and my mother said to me because she was
in the audience obviously great job
Lauren great I was so embarrassed my
turn but I did it for every week I would
go to Nathan's and that's how I kind of
started uh talking to people and one
thing led to another
did your mother ever ask you Warren are
you gay it's okay but are you gay you're
doing fashion shows with dogs you're
doing you know maybe are you you're an
eccentric guy you're a feminine my
mother asked me if I was gay when I was
in college yeah she said are you gay I
know you're in the acting it's okay if
you go absolutely and I didn't tell her
for two weeks that I wasn't I you know
it's interesting Michael I was never
asked that you would never asked well I
was never I've been asked that before
it's been written about you know things
like that which is fine it would have
been a great question because I got a
call last week on my radio show with a
guy that asked me if his dog was gay
because he's mounting other male dogs at
the park and I said so what if he is
what's the big deal but the guy was
worried that his dog was gay now that's
the mentality of a [__]
I mean I mean I don't even know if you
can yeah because it's it's weird you
never think about well that dog's
humping another no dogs was that is that
dog gay you know when my autobiography
came out one of the first interviews I
did was with Howard Stern on his show
because Howard Stern Baba Bowie I used
to buy leashes from him on Long Island
years ago so we knew each other well so
when the book came out Baba Booey called
me said well we want you on the Stern
Show I said all right I'm gonna be in
for a little I get on to start the first
thing Howard asked me to if animals
could be gay and I responded of course
they can be all animals can be gay so
yeah it's it's it's a concept that
people don't understand but let me just
remark this if the dog humps your leg
Michael don't feel flattered your leg is
not that attractive he's dominating you
that's what the humping's are and you
shouldn't allow that
um no no you shouldn't allowed you
shouldn't allow that you shouldn't allow
anyone to be to dominate you you can't
allow anyone to hop your legs yes now
now I gotta ask this just because you're
here now we don't have to get into it
because this is about you but what
my mother
your sister
let's just say eccentric
a little out there at times uh
Fleetwood Mac sang a song you can go
your own way she has she has what was it
like growing up with my mother oh you
have no idea you have no idea it was it
was she'll laugh at this she will she's
probably laughing now
she used to beat me up
come on if you would take a baseball bat
like a plastic baseball bat and beat me
over the head I'm three years younger
than her I would get in trouble because
I would break into a room if a
girlfriend was getting dressed
um Nona was Nona was NoDa was always
Peter Pan and she'd always be Peter Pan
she will never be older than 15 years
old and growing up with it was
interesting because you know I got to be
honest with you we didn't spend a whole
lot of time together when we were real
young we lived in a a project in in
Rockaway Beach it was one room we lived
in the same room together
um but once we once we moved I was 10 so
she was 14 she was into boys back then
so at that time we didn't spend a whole
lot of time but I gotta be honest with
you I
I love my sister a hundred percent but
absolutely there's no way she'd be
walking the streets by herself she needs
company she needs company she needs
company yeah that's true it's uh I look
cool I'm telling yeah look who you're
telling
inside of you is brought to you by
Harry's Razors guys
I mean these razors are top-notch gosh
why aren't they around Ryan when I was
doing Smallville with the bald head
would be nice look at well you go to the
grocery store and you or wherever you go
to get your blades and they're always
way expensive you're like how are three
blades this much money
and they're not even the highest quality
blades what if I told you you can get
the highest quality blades and it's
cheaper and it's delivered to your door
so you never run out it sounds like a
dream it is a dream because Harry's
Razors make dreams come true it's true
in a sea of options it's hard to find
quality razors you can depend on Harry
makes it easy they consistently give you
better razors and in-store options at
the best price uh you know they have
this deal it's uh the quality shave
without the hassle with a three dollars
Harry's trial set three dollars folks
the starter set is the 13 value for just
three dollars at harrys.com slash inside
that's Harry's h-a-r-r-y-s it includes
five blade German engineered razor
weighted handle foaming gel and a travel
cover
come on plus you can schedule
replacement blade delivery plus you can
schedule replacement blade delivery
whenever you need them with refills as
low as two dollars also shaving creams
for before and after you shave body
washes hydrating lotions and more blades
are made in their own Factory in Germany
that hold up better than ever and I'm
telling you I've shaved with them like
even after eight or ten times I'm like I
should change the blade I'm like I don't
think I need to they're that sharp they
just they're good quality blades Harry
has the highest customer satisfaction in
the Shaving industry and they're still
offering a no risk trial don't like your
shave no worries it's on them say the
hassle set up your delivery and get the
best quality shave with Harry's save the
best quality shave with Harry's get a 13
starter set for just three dollars at
harrys.com inside that's harrys.com
inside for a three dollar starter set
I mean you've seen it all I mean you
know you uh you know the family you uh
you grew up in what was it like having
Ruth and Charlie as as parents I mean
because you know I didn't get to
experience Charlie a lot because he was
pretty sick and he died young at 64. he
was in the war he you know he had a lot
of problems and um and you know Ruth was
you know and by the way Charlie was like
blue collar and he you know he he was
definitely a man's man who you know
worked on cars and had his own auto
shops and Ruth was like the first woman
on the Book of World Encyclopedia yeah
she was the first manager yeah so it's
Charlie was an interesting guy in fact I
just started reading a book about him
because I want to understand him better
now
um he spent six years in New Guinea he
was in the Army before World War II
started I have a telegram on December
7th sending him right overseas so we
spent a lot of people down he was in two
plane crashes malaria all this kind of
stuff and he never talked about it when
he came home an amazing father but
difficult father from the perspective a
lot different than yours is because he
survived that when he came home uh every
day he was in a survival mode he never
worried about making money tomorrow we
woke up one day and the lights were off
the gas was off the water was off he
never worried about tomorrow because he
was in that survival mode he worried
about today in terms of a father he
taught me how to use tools he taught me
how to uh uh tremendous respect for me
taught me how to be a man but I think he
kind of was he patient with you no no he
wasn't patient with me he wasn't and he
also wanted to focus on things he liked
for example he was into bowling I was
into baseball we went bowling all right
I was at the baseball we went to the car
races he went to the car races right so
it was he he was in this mode where
I think he knew he always said I'm never
going to make it I'm never going to make
it the 40 I'm never he always kind of
knew that he was never going to be on
but I got to be honest with you as a
father I don't think I could have done
better wow yeah yeah he was he loved me
I remember coming home sometimes in in
a little drugged up maybe when I was
younger and he was he was sitting at the
kitchen table having his morning coffee
and he knew but he never uh would never
confronted with me he was excited when I
was in volunteer fight of him yeah he
was he was a
we lost him way too young and I you know
what
at this age now I'm first starting to
understand him really yeah first
starting all this time
I just said it was just an amazing guy
he he he he he there's nothing he would
not do
for for his family except work I mean
but in other words if I got in trouble
which was pretty often the big guys with
Jason me Charlie was out there it's the
kind of guy would say to me listen
Lauren here's the deal
if you go out there and you got to get
into a fight don't come home if you lose
and in a jokingly way but that's that
Macho approach it but he took me even to
this day uh my wife this one Denise will
tell you if there's something broken
I'll be able to fix it because he taught
me how his hands were like gold he
taught me how to use my hands that's
amazing that's a gift yeah absolutely
and Ruth
look if you think if I think of my
grandmother I think of strong and
stubborn as [__] and just but at the
same time
just you wanted to be around her I
always wanted to be around her I just
she if you pissed her off she had a
temper like nobody she would come out
there and she would you know she'd throw
a shoe at you no shoes by the way they
were stuff them suckers would turn coins
oh my God it was amazing but she was
also great she was like Hanukkah claws
she came downstairs dressed as like a
Santa Claus Hanukkah Claws and she was
great but she was uh was she more of a
disciplinarian
yeah I think she and my mother bang butt
heads a little bit well I think I think
mothers and daughters always do yeah
they they just they just were you know
they would go at it a lot they you know
because no one was not an easy jogs he
was really wild yeah who used to turn
boy crazy when she was younger but she
was wild Ruth was was God I'm gonna
sound uh
she was like again the most incredible
mother in other words I sucked in school
literally I mean I could care less about
school I think she spent more time in my
high school uh last year than I did I
was always in trouble being sent here
for this and for that she loved her
family and she would literally murder
for her family 100
um but she was the most fun person
everything in life was a song everything
was a tune I think when she was younger
I don't remember this exactly but I
think during World War II she she sung
with the Uso at some of their clubs in
New York City she had a great voice I
have her singing like to herself she
didn't know I was filming her that's
amazing yeah she she was just you're
right you had to be around with her if
she pissed her off you mean I want to be
around her yeah but if she loved you
and no matter whether you were family or
just a friend I mean she had some people
move into the house when we had some
places for rent that that I would be
scared to live with oh I know she would
make friends with them and talk with
them she just liked to be around a great
lady she just loved her she was I
remember she was like give me that joint
there you go it doesn't work Adam and I
my brother were there Ryan and uh she
goes give me that that [__] doesn't work
and she took a hit
and it was about 40 minutes later I go
you're high aren't you she goes get out
of here all right and then she ate a
whole pizza I remember smoking good
joint with her in my house I know she
went to a bag of donuts so it's it's but
that was the type of mother she was she
would never say don't do it oh my god
look if I did it I would be in a
boarding school like you do that you're
out of this house it was so I don't know
why but it was so
you know everything was no you do that
it was just it was never like you're
where you're talking about have you ever
seen your mother after she smoked the
joint probably not I have I don't want
to see that you're absolutely right yeah
I've seen Nona when she smoked the joint
and if you I love her and she's my
sister now I would do anything but if
she if you ever swear when she smoked
the joint you would absolutely want to
put her away
[Laughter]
yeah I can imagine that um all right so
back to the to the career because it's
pretty crazy guys
um the things that you got to do and
encounter and be a part of uh you know
how did it start out where you start you
were starting to be invited or as a
guest on these shows like Regis and and
um Gary not Gary Collins Aaron magazines
number first talk show in the country
yeah Letterman how did this all start I
you know it was kind of because I was
doing something that no one else was
doing at the time I was starting to get
little tidbits of press plus the fact I
was doing a lot of rescue work I was a
peace officer for the state of New York
for the league for animal protection
voluntary I got no pay for it but I had
to carry a gun 24 hours I had a badge
and I would go out and investigate
animal abuse and and wow a quick story I
remember going getting called into where
a dog was being really abused a pitbull
was being really abused uh at this at
this uh location somewhere on Long
Island I'm not going to give you
location so I go there about 10 11
o'clock at night I knock on the door and
these three grubby looking guys answer
the door right out of a biker movie and
they say yeah what do you want I said
well I got a complaint about your uh
your dog being abused and he said who
are you and I said I'm with the animal
league for protection he said you're a
dog cop
you're a dog huh so then then and it was
it was a motorcycle gang I'll mention
their name for the pagans but a big Club
on the East Coast very very aggressive
club and we started talking they knew I
was in the military and after that
confrontation we started smoking you
joined together I trained the dog we
became good friends but
it was all worked out it all worked out
but so I started getting a little
notoriety you know I started training
some Mobsters dogs you know Carlo
Gambino in a lot of Gambino's dogs yeah
yeah I mean why would you take that job
let me tell you Michael I knew who I was
training I knew who Carlo Gambino was by
the time I trained his dog that dog was
cooking pasta and speaking Italian no
doubt mom but here's what happened is
once you train or once you work with a
monster either as their lawyer as their
accountant their doctor they all only
use the same doctors to start became
like the the one to the the mob it was
it's kind of interesting
um Henry Hill you know Henry Hills he
was the uh Ray Liotta played Henry Hill
in uh Goodfellas yeah I was at his house
when he was counting
hundred dollar bills with these cash
machines I was working you met Hill oh
yeah I worked with his dog and one of my
closest friends Nico who you remember
yeah built part of his house yeah and so
so I got to work with all these monsters
and again are really nice to you yeah
you know what did you ever see anything
that was like oh [__] any moments where
you just go
I bet there's a dead body here I didn't
think of a dead body because I I pull up
to the uh Brownstone house in uh in uh
Brownsville Brooklyn a real sleazy
neighborhood so I'm going to train this
dog and I pull up to the house and I go
to the front and there's two big guys
standing right out of a movie I mean
Hawaiian shirts the whole bit Michael
right out of a movie so I walk and they
say who you I said wrong name's Warren
next time you gotta train the dog
and they said what the organizer
whoever's owned the dog so they had a
Neapolitan mass of an Italian dog so
they let me go downstairs into this this
basement apartment
to meet the guy who owned the dog and
I'm looking around and I'm looking
around I say what looks different here
there's like 20 telephones and desks
over there there's another 20 telephones
and desks over there and I'm saying to
myself doesn't look like they're raising
money for muscular dystrophy over here
it was a bookie join they were just
taking all these calls in they were
always nice to me uh they always paid
cash no contracts uh but quite honestly
and paid you well oh and they did pay
well absolutely this is a quick story
about one of the real big monsters I
just married Faye
maybe a year and we were poor so we
would sit and eat dinner on the floor we
had no dining room table we lived in a
studio apartment in Long Beach not too
far from where you lived yeah so the
bottom line was I would get to know this
guy Walter who was The Bodyguard for
this this major mobster and he would
talk to me and after six or eight weeks
of work with the dog we get to know each
other and they said there's one thing
what would you want you know I would
love to have a dinette set for me and my
wife so we don't have to eat on the
floor so I finished training his dog
they were real happy with it the day I
left they gave me an envelope and said
do it I didn't open the envelope in
front of me I got into my car my 1970
duster got into my car up in the
envelope and it was a check there not a
check that was Cash there for 500 and
the note that says go buy that dinette
set
and you did and I did so yeah they were
they were really nice to work with I
listen I don't admire what they did on
the other side of course but in terms of
going to the homes and working with
their dogs I never had any problems with
anyone a few of them are dead and few of
them got killed yeah it happens and so
you're you're getting some notoriety
you're getting and what's the first show
that goes hey they want you in the
morning show what was the first kind of
big one that they got they saw they
would bring this guy in you know I think
what was that News 12 Long Island it was
like the local news cable station so I
did that show are you excited were you
nervous the first time probably yeah
yeah I'm nervous to this day I'm nervous
now what get out of here when I go on
the radio I have to write my name down
on a piece of paper so I don't forget it
that's how anxious I am even doing this
42 years 42 years every single one maybe
five weeks open 42 weeks on the air you
know I feel the same way maybe it's in
the blood I always feel nervous about
everything I think why aren't you relax
more I'm more a little more relaxed now
because it's the right meds but many
years ago I was working with a director
uh Harold Prince do you know who that is
yeah how Prince was a good friend of
mine in fact I just came across a letter
from me sent to me from Europe the other
day and and he taught me he taught me a
lot of things and he just one of those
things he taught me was
um
it's like if you're if you're not
nervous you're doing something wrong
well he did mostly Broadway right yeah
so when he was doing and I was at the
same time when I was doing his I was
doing uh dogs for some uh some dance
groups as well he said to me listen when
you stop being afraid you suck
when when you don't have those
butterflies in your stomach the
excitement or the or the the passion or
it's gone so I have that I mean no
matter if you think I'm lying then I'm
nervous no no I don't think you're lying
I think I took his Annex before I got
here get out
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh do those thoughts keep you
from showing care when it counts new and
improved Dove men plus care
antiperspirant with 72-hour sweat and
odor protection and one quarter
moisturizing cream helps you forget
about your underarms so you can be
present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant or ever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection you feel you feel so
laid back I never look at you and go
he's nervous and wow I like hearing that
and that's what a lot of people
listening would like to hear like
somebody who's been on the radio for so
long has done so much TV has been around
I mean you trained uh Lily tomlin's dogs
and brought them to the Emmys yeah I
mean the list we'll talk about I want to
hear some of these stories but like
I mean how do you not be I mean you've
done so much it's just kind of like it's
it's nice to know that like hey you're
human do you get anxiety still do you
get have you do you go through
depression do you deal with that stuff
how do you deal with it yeah you know I
have my own anxieties and I have my own
depressions at times never with the
animals always with the people
um and everyone deals with it
differently you know I I'll smoke a
joint I mean I'm not into any heavy
drugs whatsoever so if I come home after
you know when we come home back then
after working with maybe
12 13 15 18 hours a day I mean I was
never home I ate dinner with Johnny
Carson every night seriously because
that's how I came home and so it was
foreign
but then it just it just I just kept
going Michael like you just gotta keep
going and then I was training I started
working with some of the sporting events
and my name got out there and then I did
they called me to do a uh before Regis
and Kathy Lee had a TV show Regis was
doing a show on Lifetime television if
you have a lifetime television oh yeah
and they would call me in and I'd bring
in snakes or goats whatever and so in
fact when Regis and Kathy Lee started
their show Kathy Lee wasn't the host I
go before Kathy Lee it was a lady by the
name of Ann Abernathy and then when when
Anne Abernathy left it was uh uh Steve
garvey's wife Cindy Garvey was the host
so Cindy Garvey and Regis and it was a
local good morning you knew them back in
the day yeah it was it was a New York
show not syndicated then one of Vista
picked it up uh in fact I was on the
demo reel on the demo wheel I brought on
like 22 Golden Retriever puppies how
could they blow it so yeah I did Regis
and Kathy Lee for all those years it was
it was a fun show to do
um if you ever get bitten on on a live
show like some dog you I could tell you
have not by a dog I was doing a snake I
was doing a show in San Francisco it was
a show called Mac and Muttley I just
finished teaching a dog how to scuba
dive it was for the TV show so anyway
I'm doing this whole thing this is my
life Michael I'm doing this I'm doing
this show Mac and but they fly me out to
uh to San Francisco and I do a bunch of
shows at a time so I finished doing that
then I finished doing this I just did a
segment on rodents now I'm doing a
segment on snakes and the bottom line
was that I didn't get a chance to wash
my hands under my own stupidity I went
to pick up this rattlesnake and I have
the smell of rodents on my hands so he
launched in tonight he launched into me
and I spent two days in hospital in San
Francisco and had to take you to know
this do you she almost died I didn't
almost die but I was pretty sick and
then I had uh what does it feel like to
be
bitten by a rattlesnake what's that
feeling are the breathing the breathing
the nerves you know the type of toxin
that they have you feel like you're like
I could die I I you want to die it's
that bad yeah it is that bad you want to
die you want to die and it was a young
rattlesnake and the younger the
rattlesnake the more Venom they they
give you you know the oldest snake save
their venom just use enough to do with
it but the younger ones just they put it
all out there so and then there was a
time I was working I did a TV show in
New York for six years called Saturday
morning live and it was hosted by Gene
Rayburn let me just imagine her old
school he was right he was my mentor I
mean this guy taught me everything and I
was doing a segment on uh on on lizards
and uh before I went on I was working
with an animal called a big large I
don't know I think it was like
kind of big large furry animal I'm
trying to think of what it was now
anyway it took my finger and it bit me
before I went on the air and 80
something stitches my finger was hanging
and and but I didn't want to miss the
segments adrenaline kept it through it I
I went we took a break I went back put a
bunch of bandages on put my hand in my
pocket and finished a segment and and
and and but then because I did that show
Gene would have all these friends come
on you know Charles Nelson Riley Betty
White uh all his friends would come on
it was amazing to get to meet Jesus all
of these people that are idled and then
I got called to do our magazine and I
would come out to Westinghouse out here
and I got to hang out with Liberace help
I helped train living I watch pictures
of that we got you got to send me these
pictures of the post yeah there was some
just great shots it was it was exciting
I look back at it now and and people say
to me what about the dangers you know I
was training guard dogs at the time as
well yeah uh once I had a gun at my head
and once I had a knife at my throat at
Hunts Point Market in the Bronx I was
dropping off a guard dog at three
o'clock in the morning Hunts Point
Market is where all the players go to
buy the fruit you know the fruit vendors
the mavens and so I was dropping a dog
off there to do some protection work and
uh you almost got killed there the guy
pulled the knife on me luckily the dog
reacted good training Warren the dog
reacted grabbed his hand took him down
and we were able to get away
when you were when you did Letterman
Letterman was called the David Letterman
show yeah at the time and you sort of
became sort of friendly with him
David Letterman shy was working with his
dogs so he got my name oh here's how
David Letterman got my name I believe I
forget how I still have the t-shirt that
you say David Letterman it was a Morning
Show and he had a little jazz band in
the back and we got to know each other
really well Fay and I would hang out we
go out to the Hamptons with him and his
girlfriend at the time Meryl Marco uh we
became friendly in fact a couple of
times he was hosting the Tonight Show
they flew me in to be a guest with his
on The Tonight Show
um trained his dog's Bob and Stan then
you drive around in his duster he wanted
to buy my dude and he would try to get
on my case to buy my duster over and
over again but I wasn't I wasn't selling
it does he was a really neat guy Dave
was kind of interesting quiet a nice guy
and then the funny part is when I
started working with him uh later on he
was doing he was doing the Late Night
show and I was working with his dog by
the way I was training all the dogs for
Saturday Night Live at that point if you
saw a dog or a cat or a horse on
Saturday Night Live I was there Denise
my wife were just talking about it
um I did a segment with uh
um Glenn Close where she was playing a
dog show a dog show judge where the show
goes wrong so I had all these dogs
around her she's standing on the podium
as the judge and all the dogs attacked
her it was a great great scene um so I
got to work with all of them you know
I'm going back to uh the Bellucci days
all these people so every week I was and
it was a pain in the ass show to do
because I have to go there and and be
there Friday and be there Saturday
morning then have dress rehearsal see
what they're going to put on what
they're not going to put on wasn't there
some SNL actor who thought he was being
upstaged by the animals and got upset
I'm not going to mention his name uh
John uh what the hell's his last name
Belushi no not John Belushi oh God candy
no yeah he wasn't on there he was on
yeah that's the ticket oh yeah yeah
that's the ticket yeah oh God yeah he's
actually you know he's a nice guy yeah
I'm friendly with him but he was a
little he goes I don't want these dab
stage he was doing a segment I think it
was with Dana Carter I don't remember
and it was a segment they had this there
was a bloodhound involved blood has a
beautiful dog man they were being
upstaged by the blood neither one of
them are attractive looking guys the
dogs upstairs and they were pissed off
they cut the dog I still got paid but
they cut the dog and then for the
Letterman show we did the suit of suet
where we addressed David Letterman in
the suit of suet and I put deer and
raccoons and possums in a cage with them
and none of them would go near him
really because they kept the suit in the
uh in the commissary at NBC and the food
sucks at the commissary it probably
smelled so bad that the animal said you
know what I'm not going near him the
character was Tommy Flanagan yeah that's
the ticket yeah yeah me and my wife
Morgan Fairchild whom I've seen naked
um wow I mean all the stuff you've done
it's crazy I remember I saw you on
Letterman one night
and you brought a pig on set
to the Letterman show and David looks at
and goes uh wow Warren uh where does
this pit come from where did you get
this pig and and you said oh I you know
I just actually got it uh tonight um you
know here in Manhattan on the streets
because where he goes where do you get a
pig and you know what I think we all
know where to get a pig at this hour
he he would drive me crazy he said I
picked smart so I went out and I
literally bought this pig for 35 and the
day before I did the show with Dave I
spent the night with the pig training it
working with it so I get some response
on the show didn't work out no he didn't
work out too great but anyway the pig's
name was spotty black and white Pig so I
bought I bought him on the show and
they've had this whole thing with him
but then I had spent the night with the
pig I can't bring her back to the farmer
I kept him now I had the pig on Long
Island in Oceanside my hometown
for like eight months and he kept
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
people would say to me what I said some
red dog from hungry
and then and that's when that's when
Fang and I ultimately we had to buy this
Farm
can you imagine buying five acres with a
house and a barn on it for twenty nine
thousand dollars can you imagine this
slum I lived in I mean they have to go
outside to pump the water how many
animals lived in that farm I had rescued
30 dogs at that point 27 cats six
chickens six Ducks two pet pigs Corky
and spotty Partridge you know what and
yeah but every one of these animals God
I loved every you know I think I get
tears when I think about some you met
Shannon yeah you know and Shannon yeah I
remember it was in the um it was in Ruth
his mother my grandmother's garage and
uh you know they were keeping them there
temporarily and then you know so I'll go
she goes don't go in there you don't
want to go in there and I went in there
and I looked at the cage and just me as
a little boy and dog Shannon is like
I'm like oh [__] this thought dog looked
like it was gonna just small me but yeah
there's always animals sometimes at
Roots house there was always Shepherds
there's always dogs I mean you taught me
and I think you know the rest of us like
that you know
how much love to give animals and how
important it is and like you know now
I'm on you know the board of your the
hugs and kisses and hugs and kisses
animal fund and and um you know and
you're you're always doing this you're
always battling you're always trying to
find homes you're always trying to
rescue Animals still to this day well
I'm so tired of people having to be
dominant over their dog all the time you
know having to be the boss or the alpha
I hate that [__] I hate that word
Alpha that word really pisses me off
okay I like my dog I like to negotiate
with my dog I want my dog to be behaved
to a certain point but no better behave
than I am so in other words what it took
me all these years to establish and I
have the hugs and kisses approach to
training is being used by I have emails
from trainers I trained to trainers
years ago then now the number one
trainer in Pennsylvania or Nevada or
here I just explained to them and I
taught them all listen if you want
something to listen to you 100 of the
time you better buy something with
batteries
if you have a dog it's not going to
respond enjoy the good enjoy the bad
training educate them I like the word
edu that's fine but it really took me
yes because back then everyone was into
the you know you got to be the boss and
jerk the dog around and electronic
college and prong collars and all that
[__] they should go on people not on
the animals let the dog be a dog what do
they live you know how hard it is losing
a dog they live for what 12 13 14 years
educate them but let them enjoy life let
them dig a hole in the backyard geez
when people say no matter I call last
week where someone said my dog's digging
holes in the backyard so he said crawl
around your backyard how interesting is
it for you I had them go out and buy a
kiddie pool fill the kiddie pool with
sand and dirt go in the kiddie pool make
believe they were digging entice the dog
to come in so now that's the only where
the dog digs is because now we have his
own sandbox in their backyard rather
than people saying well yell at the dog
and throw this and squirt them with
water now the dog has a box to go dig in
and enjoying himself why stop that
I love it and you know I always think of
you when I when I see
dogs being walked and sometimes really
irritates me when you see someone on
their phone while they're walking their
dog this is this is like a dog has an
hour
maybe two hours a day or whatever half
an hour for people when they walk it's
their time it's not your time so you
said to me I go you know my answer is
kind of jerking me over here and wants
to pee on everything and wants to go
here and you're like it's her time
exactly let her do what you want exactly
she's gonna tell you when and where to
pee right so yeah it's a good example
the other day I was walking around Santa
Monica
and this guy has his dog beautiful dog a
blended breed I use the word Blended now
and the dog's lifting his leg and peeing
on a telephone Paul by the way you might
not notice but the higher your dog lifts
his leg the more dominant the dog is
this dog was really given a high kick
the dogs lifted his leg on top and the
guy's going to hurry up come on come on
hurry up hurry up hurry
hurry and I kept thinking to myself man
would I love to be behind this guy at a
urinal when I'd love to just stand
behind this guy yelling all right let's
go buddy come on man hurry up pee I
gotta go I got in that thing yet you
take your dog out for a walk you hit the
nail on the head get off your phone
focus on your dog it's your time with
your dog it's the dogs walk let him
enjoy and all the time people say well
why is my dog sniffing the butt It
embarrasses me when a dog sniffs the
butt of another dog that's the internet
that's Google that's Yahoo for the dog
everything your dog wants to know the
hormones the food in the neighborhood is
in the butt so let your dog sniff the
butt it's not the end of the world
only for dogs like oh you got Ryan
laughing now I mean you've done it wow
um what's the most what's the biggest
misconception or one of the biggest
misconceptions about
um about training your dogs or things
that you hear about dogs that people
assume because they've heard it for so
long that you're like that's not true
it's it's a fallacy that's a myth
there's so many like is there is are
there mouths the health the the cleaner
than humans yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of argument over where the
dog's mouth is cleaner or it's not
cleaner uh quite honestly I'd much
rather be kissed by a dog and have a
dog's mouth on me than most of the
people I know right now
um so yeah it's it's people a lot of
misconceptions I'll give you an example
people think that when a dog when a dog
growls it's aggressive behavior dogs
smile and sometimes what it is
appeasement Behavior sometimes they'll
raise your lip and show their teeth not
an aggressive but it's just an
appeasement approach uh in fact some
dogs will actually raise them up high
where you think they're growling and
when a dog does growl say thank you now
I know that sounds eccentric in heaven
forbid Michael I should ever be called
eccentric but imagine when a dog growls
what he's doing is saying to the person
I'm not feeling good right now I'm a
little anxious to stressed out leave me
alone it's like if you're in a really
weird really bad mood tell me if I know
maybe we'll talk about this tomorrow
rather than getting into an argument
with them so that's really what a dog is
doing very often when they're grounded
just letting you know something's
bugging them and a lot of people just
assume the dog's aggressive and mean so
when Blanche is sees a dog outside the
window goes then she goes to the other
window and this and she keeps going and
going going just let her do it let her
enjoy it don't stop her it's you know
what can you say no blast stop it's okay
it's okay perfect you hit the nail on
the head because when I get the calls
and says my dog box like crazy when he
sees another dog outside the window or
he sees a person go by and hey what do
you do when you see your dog barking
standing on the couch barking out the
window and they say I go over to the dog
and like shut up stop it knock it off
wait till daddy comes home and I said
you know what you just did you just
joined the dogs in you're just walking
alongside the dog from the dog's point
of view so what I do when I have a dog
that barks when my dog's barking at the
window I go over to him and say thank
you I appreciate you saved my life but I
got it from here
I love it that's the way how do you know
if a duck because we talk about mental
health in this but how do you know if
your dog is suffering from depression or
anxiety what signs are there yeah
they're the signs are you know lack of
appetite uh not enjoying the things he
used to enjoy uh being more fatigued
than normal changing personality uh uh
hiding walking away from you I just this
segment recently on is it possible dogs
can suffer from the blues and they can
but also you have to remember Michael
this is so so true having trained over
40 000 animals I'm telling you from the
bottom of my heart that animals take on
the way we feel so if I'm working with a
person that's a depressed person
generally I'm gonna have a dog that may
be a little depressed if I'm working
with a hyper crazy
we talked about some of my famous
clients Rodney Dangerfield
guy was a maniac dog was a maniac
I'm just telling you the way it was what
did you tell me you said that you you
you came up and it was just like out of
a movie he answers his door and he's
like hey Warren you got to help me he's
in a robe my my dog jumps on my leg with
his eyes closed no respect Warren in a
robe that I went where if I was a Hermit
living in Montana that's how so he was
talking about this little dog and the
poodle man I think it was named Nico I
don't remember now anyway he was just
it's exactly that and he said the
greatest line I told you ever heard was
Warren
talk about no respect the dog humps my
leg but before he does he closes his
eyes that was just and then going to his
car he would invite me and fade all his
concerts hey Cajun cast I'm sure
painting cash of course he had he had
Dangerfield me a favor would be regulus
if Dangerfield's glove we would go there
but you could not go backstage at a
Dangerfield concert and not be stoned by
the time you walk down I'm not saying he
was smoking but just everybody was
everybody else was oh yeah I've never
seen you but everyone everyone else
great time Lily Tomlin
you got stone with her a lot didn't you
she was a great lady I love Lily and and
Jane well oh just incredible people was
Lily Tom because you know there's that
famous video Ryan what was the movie
where the outtakes they saved and it
shows her screaming at uh David Russell
and David Russell screaming back at her
and it's just this mess all have you
ever seen it no I haven't oh it's insane
did you ever see her that side of her no
I never saw that side of her you know
it's interesting though but
working with at the time I was working
with her she had a Norwich Terrier the
dog's name was Tess do you remember the
story of Sybil the woman with 100
personalities or 80 personalities you
know that story it was a popular book
years ago the woman had many
personalities yeah we had to watch it in
the AP Psych class so there you go every
psych Classic
this woman had like I think 13 different
personalities so I started and I'd come
out here and Lily at that time lived in
the old uh I think it was the old WC
Fields estate it was painted hot pink
inside now remember the movie The
Incredible Shrinking Woman oh yeah
that's how the house was furnished the
the the the cassette play that they made
really big for the movie was a living
room table the rocking chair from Rowan
and Martin that was at the poolside so
she was an incredible lady but working
with her dog was like working with civil
the dog had multiple personalities and
I'm trying to be analytical and say why
is this Warren well Lily at that point
was practicing three or four different
personalities every day she might be
Ernestine at one minute she's focused
and she's someone else so they'll picked
up on all these person now is it picked
up on that so if I were to spend 10
minutes with anyone's dog uh I would or
cat I would probably know more about
that person than they would want me to
know because the personality goes from
one end of the leash right to the other
you know what's weird is with Blanche is
um you know and I I don't think I've
ever even I swear I don't think I've
ever yelled at her I just I unless she's
in the battle laughs come on let's go
but not yelling like don't hey you know
or just stop you know but for some
reason I had this little tiny there's
these little band pillows I have in the
basement and one time I just like
tossed it not even at her five feet from
her and she kind of cowered and then
came over to me and like was like
wanting love and I and so if anybody
ever throws something near her or
and she wasn't ever abused she was never
uh I've been with her I rescued her
since she was a baby and I'm like what
is that did she look mad at her just one
you know just one thing it only takes
one thing dogs learn through the
associative memory so in other words if
you do nine things perfectly and the
tenth time you blow it sometimes that's
the time they remember
um yeah so it's it's
they're just so amazing it's not just
the dogs it's the people you know I had
the opportunity of working in Europe uh
doing it you know actually walking with
dogs right along the Berlin Wall we'll
get into that particularly wow but
anyway I was doing some type of training
there called
training which is a combination of
obedience uh protection uh tracking
agility uh just
just amazing what these dogs can learn
and you know
when when
9 11 took place
I was in Santa Monica
and I got a call from the New York State
actually New York City canine unit
and
they asked me if I would come to New
York
and evaluate the needs of the NYPD
canine unit because I had the the Petco
Foundation was going to donate money and
before they donated they wanted my
approval
so I said to Denise I said all right I
gotta go it's my hometown
the tunnel planes how am I gonna get to
New York so I have my 1992 Ford Explorer
at 200 mile 200 000 miles on it drove
cross country get to New York and then
they tell me Well the canine dogs are at
the at the Brooklyn Navy yard so I got
there and I was supposed to evaluate
them and the first thing the the command
of this and I won I known you for years
I know what you do hop in the back of
the truck while going to Ground Zero I
wasn't expecting to go to Ground Zero
and I went there and and and and and and
and and
it was the most horrible experience I
ever had and I've been through War zones
but the most horrible experience I've
had but on a positive note the dogs were
absolutely amazing
but interesting they weren't finding
survivors and that's what these dogs
were trained to do
so what they had to do is kind of every
once in a while they would have a person
play a victim so the dog would find
somebody that they could rescue that was
alive it was just a a heart I mean to
this day to this day I have I have
nightmares about being there yeah really
but I was able the bottom line is I saw
their needs and I was able to donate uh
a quarter of a million dollars to the
NYPD
that's um that's awesome that is awesome
also um you know we don't have to talk
about it too much but like you know a
lot of people I talk to people guests
and you know my friend Zach just lost
his dad
uh and you know loss is part of life and
you know you lost your first wife and
Faye my aunt Faye who I loved but you
lost her very young I mean how long were
you married I knew Faye when she was 12
years old I was three years older than
her
I was attracted to her even when I knew
her very young she was I was in a I was
in a little gang I was a little Greaser
I was in a little gang she was in a
little sorority but her older sister
would not let me near her wouldn't that
be near us so I was home on leave one
day from Langley Air Force Base in
Virginia and I was with my friend Jay
you know my friend oh my gosh fight
tooth decay with Dr J there you go so
we're driving down the street and I look
out of my car and I see this girl and
she looks so familiar but I couldn't
figure out who she was so I honked my
horn she looked at me I think she
flipped me off she looked at me and we
drove off and then it took me a day or
two to figure out who she was and then I
realized it was it was Fay now I know
she was like 17 18. and I was still in
his service I was only on my leave and
that's how I met her so we got married
when I got out of the service she had
just turned 18 turned down a scholarship
to Radcliffe and married me and we got
married in uh in Woodstock New York and
and and in front of in a judge's house
where his wife was my best man his
daughter was and and we were married 19
years her mom and dad at the wedding no
no me and her yeah it was just you were
married 19 years we married 19 years and
uh and great years and she was diagnosed
with melanoma skin cancer how did she
find the cancer was it on a belt or
something yeah she was she had diabetes
so she went to a diabetic doctor and and
she had noticed on her stomach she
showed the doctor that you know it was
around Thanksgiving like November and
she said you know I went to my belt and
I know it's a little blood on this this
thing that I have and that's that's no
big deal but you know what there's a
dermatologist across this across the oh
why don't you go check it out just the
float she went over there checked it out
and it turned out to be melanoma and
back then you know they have a lot more
cures now they didn't have it then we I
went through every every dollar I had
legitimately every dollar I had trying
to go for alternative therapies but
listen to this she was diagnosed in
November
and she was up
she was uh she died in May so it was so
fast and I was totally dependent on her
and and and and Faye and I had just
finished writing the book pederobics so
we were doing all these these shows
locally in New York we were being caught
People magazine did a four-page article
on saying myself calling us the Jane
fonders of the dog world I saw that
article People magazine uh so so it was
a it was a hard
hard hard loss but on that note
I have to be the luckiest man in the
world to find love a second time
absolutely absolutely Denise is just and
someone listen I am the most difficult
person no I think I might be well you
probably could be that's true but I'm
like second to you I mean yes maybe no
my mother is first yeah yeah I think
maybe so that would be the question this
is the would you rather live with
Michael I have to live with his mother
yeah well you travel a lot I'd rather
live with you yeah maybe yeah you can
get away um man that's you know how do
you how do you remember getting through
that time do you remember just working
as much as you can staying as busy as
possible uh or do you remember kind of
like you're in a lull and it's like
you're feeling it every day you're kind
of numb going through the motions I'm
gonna tell you things that I've never
told anybody
there were twice in my life where I
contemplated suicide
lunch was at a place called buckaro
beach in Hampton Bay Virginia I was just
back from overseas
didn't know what was going on
and I remember walking on a sea wall
why do I want to go on
somehow I did
and again after Faye died because it was
so quick
you know we were young I didn't know
what I was going to do where I was going
to go I didn't even know what bank we
used
and I remember walking on the beach Long
Beach Little Beach all you know Jones
Beach Long Island and contemplated
contemplated ending it there too and and
it's interesting
but it was her love and my love for the
animals we had
that wouldn't let me do anything I had
to keep going for them we had all these
animals at that time yeah so we had to
keep going for them just think I mean if
you didn't go how many animals wouldn't
be saved or you know yeah you know look
at that the the the the passion the
ability for us to save the thousands of
animals we've saved I it's just and yet
and yet people say isn't it rewarding oh
man it sucks because if I save ten
thousand there's 50 000 more that needs
to be saved right and and and so yeah
it's it's it's my career my life you
know I've worked with the I've trained
dogs for the presidents I've trained
dogs for for Kings I've trained dogs for
the the original Mrs Woolworth in New
York I remember she answered the door in
white gloves it was like a Betty Davis
movie
um so so many of the peoples and and so
many people in the entertainment field
you know some of the the New York City
Ballet their head people I trained all
their dogs so it was an amazing career
and I love what I did but at the same
time
when Faye was gone
for a while I lost it for a while
rightfully so though you know
man it's crazy you know a lot of people
listening probably are like well you
know it's always like yeah I want to
save animals I want to help rescue and
then when they've done listening to the
podcast they go on with their life and
they they go on it's it's inadvertent
they don't do it on purpose I think
people have hearts and they want to help
but where where could they go if you
want to rescue animals like I know my
friend Shira has the animal rescue
mission arm and uh you know I'm on the
board of that hugs and kiss you have
hugs and kisses where can they go frogs
and kisses well there's so many things
Mike a lot of people just assume that
you know what I love animals so I'm
gonna send the check that's great and we
love your money okay but there are so
many other things you can do you can be
cross-posting on internet on all the
different you know ways right social
media cross posting on social media you
can foster if you're able to yeah
um you can walk dogs at the shelters to
socialize them if you're able to uh if
you can just go down there and say if
you need help well you can be a
volunteer at many of the different
shelters uh also what you can do is
let's say you're a a really technical
person maybe some of the rescues can
need some technical help setting up
their websites so there's there's it's
not just a matter of donating money and
by the way we do love donations as well
um the thing that separates mine from
the rest is all these small
organizations do a great job they help
as many animals as they can but a lot of
them are located in areas that are are
more urban like Los Angeles and New York
right the organizations that we deal
with I just got a thank you note
yesterday from a prison in Lubbock Texas
and my Montana these are organizations
that that are saving animals off the
Native American reservations and they
have no money I mean literally they have
no money they can't put gas in their car
so these are the organizations that I
know about and these are the
organizations I don't if I send you know
people say well I'll send you a check
for ten thousand dollars if I send I
sent this prison just a small amount of
money I sent them 700 700 and I got a
letter back from saying not only did you
save all the dogs lives We rescued but
you made an entire difference on the
lives of the inmates the female inmates
at this present now that they're working
with the dogs their whole attitude has
changed and eventually they'll be
released into them so yeah that's that's
what it's all about it's it's listen
I love what I do
it has not been an easy career I've had
my butt kicked so many times yeah
um but at the same time I've got to meet
so many famous people and get to know
them and get to uh get to understand
them a lot more uh Tony down from Leave
it to Beaver big animal lover became a
good friend of ours died recently
these are people I idolized as a kid and
then I realized you know you know
working with animals and working with
people you know I did studies at the
University of Pennsylvania in Haverford
you brought this up before of uh
psychological issues that people have
and I did a lot of work with autism and
children and chronic schizophrenic in
adults and we found that for example if
a child would not relate to a therapist
if we put the child in with a puppy or a
kitten for a few minutes and they
established that non-demanding
relationship then the therapist can come
in using a dog or cat as a catalyst to
establish a relationship so these these
that's awesome that's why you know
that's why I I I've been threatened by
the state police of New York for things
I've done
um but this is what I do this is what
you know if I don't make it past
tomorrow Michael I will be the happiest
guy in the world saying you know what I
did everything I possibly could but I
got a few years left you got a few years
so if you're not going anywhere and
you're also you know dealing with it's
in remission right now but you have Pro
you have prostate can you have prostate
cancer yeah it's interesting I had a had
a 18 months of hormone therapy people on
the hormone therapy takes away a
testosterone all of a sudden I'm
starting to watch Hallmark movies on TV
I couldn't figure what was going on but
I've been off the off them a while so
yeah it seems to be it seems to be under
control right now uh I also have
rheumatoid arthritis and I go for you
know uh
injections not injections but actually
go for an infusion uh every once in a
while but the bottom line is this you
know what I can sit back and say you
know what
your your grandmother's favorite line
don't feel bad you don't have new shoes
feel bad for the guy who has no feet
that was Grandma that was wrong and I
grew up understanding that okay you know
so I have rheumatoid arthritis and I had
prostate cancer and and and you know
what here I am I have friends that lost
their lives at 18 and 19 years old so
I'm a lucky guy go get checked by the
way it's easy I have a urologist now I'm
like
it's not like I like it but I could try
to go once or twice a year and make sure
everything's working and you know it's
easy they give you a little exam it's
very I got the best doctor he's awesome
um you know yeah it's like a letterman
joke I got the best stock there everyone
has the best the best someone graduated
at the bottom of the class
that's true where could by the way if
they do want to donate money what's the
hugs and kisses they go to sample hugs
and kisses animalfun.org and just so you
know every penny that's donated to hugs
and kisses animal fund goes directly to
the animals all expenses are taken care
of by me personally
any dollar amount that has to be paid
out all done by me so every penny and as
I said the hugs and kisses animal fund
goes to organizations that most people
never know would exist because they're
so small they actually have to have a
garage sale every couple years to raise
50 bucks to spay an animal
that's where my heart is the big guys
can take care of themselves it's the
small guys in places you've never heard
of Nebraska and parts
the Podunk towns
and you also you've had this vitamin the
hugs and kisses four in one uh that I
have you gave me some of this and you
didn't by the way you didn't ask to talk
about it you didn't it speaks for itself
it's been around how long is this this
has been around since I'm young yeah
it's it's it's it's been around quite a
while and one of the reasons I
originally developed it is because
people would call me up on the radio
show all the time on WR and say ah my
dog's shedding and my cat has hot spots
and this that and the other thing
actually I would joke with people and
say well let's come to my house dog hair
is a condiment
um but the thing with the thing with the
hugs and kisses is that's when it was
originally developed for shedding but
over the years I've added to it so now
I'm gonna brag a little bit I honestly
believe that there's another product on
the market that does it all with one
supplement and it's a treat they're
shaped like little hearts hugs and
kisses and listen I've believe in it my
name is on the label right in your
picture and my picture so it you know it
works great for shedding danded dry skin
it has glucosamine chondroitin it has a
prebiotics probiotics it's a total it's
a total vitamin mineral supplement for
your dog you bought those now you know
they smell kind of good too no listen
I'm telling you as a matter of fact if
you were to go if you were to go to a
health food store and say listen I'm
shedding they would recommend less
offended biotin the same products in
hugs and kisses Blanche is never allowed
in the room because you know I do
interviews you don't want to you know
it's continuity and stuff but I mean if
there's one interview that Blanche could
be in the interview yeah I think she has
Blanche come here
where are you I was hoping she was the
one asking me the questions yeah well
plants come here
you know I can recommend the trainer for
that doc
you're not going to break it in half
give it to them
yep
you like that
sometimes I'll just break them up and
sprinkle likes it so it's all about like
when I give her a treat she's like okay
because she knows me so yeah sometimes I
just sprinkle in all their food you know
there's one girl yeah you'll notice I
guarant listen you'll notice a
difference in three or four weeks and
and the bottom line is this
healthy happy dogs
require healthy happy happy people
good girl
I'll tell you one thing
um I never thought an animal could
change my life it's it's unbelievable
I mean I never in a million years and
then you have a dog and or anything any
kind of animal and you love it so much
unconditionally and they love you
unconditionally to come home and have
that presence to have that just wake up
with kisses to take care of someone to
try and give something a good life if
you want nothing from you Mike when was
the last time a dog borrowed 10 bucks
from you when was the last time the dog
bought you a drink when you left called
you an SOB the thing about animals is
they're honest they're honest if they
don't like you you know about it right
away so I I think that's what people
appreciate about listen I gotta be I
don't think I could walk into a house
without an animal I know I couldn't do
it I they they make you feel so good
they're a real calming effect mellow and
they just make you a better person I
don't want to know people I don't want
to know people don't have animals I
think animals make you a better person
what does your shirt say uh no this is
the hugs and kisses none of my friends
woke up right
actually they go to the website the pet
show.com you're modeling this shirt on
the website yes okay so to listen to you
you still have radio programs that are
all over the country what is the show
it's called the pet show obviously we
have a local show here in Los Angeles on
krla radio and then we have a national
Canadian show uh which goes all over the
United States Canada we even heard in
Guam uh also called the Petro Nets on
Radio America the best way to find out
or check it out is is go to the website
it's easy enough to remember
thepetshow.com just remember the the
page and by the way if some of the the
listeners have questions there are
literally hundreds of YouTube videos
there and all like why does my dog do
this why does my dog hate my boyfriend
you know I have people call me up I got
a call last week that said to me if my
dog doesn't start liking my boyfriend we
can't get married
I agree with that 100 100
so here's another thing would you date
let's say I'm not going to ask you your
politics right but would you date
someone who's going to vote for a
different president than you would vote
for
probably not there you go I don't I
don't I don't I don't know I it it
really was a tough question to ask it
just depends what kind of president if
we're dealing with like the weather like
I don't hate that guy and I don't love
that guy maybe there's a but uh yeah
that's that's a good question
um this has been awesome uh so the Petro
guys where are you on Instagram and
Twitter what's your handle Instagram
Warren Eckstein
Twitter Warren Eckstein or YouTube It's
youtube.com more next time as well or
Facebook is facebook.com Warren pet talk
please follow him listen to him not
because he's my uncle and he's awesome
but he's awesome on his own he's
unbelievably knowledgeable he's written
so many books you could still get them
on Amazon probably or wherever on his
website You're Gonna Learn so much and
anybody you want to listen to you want
to listen to someone who really
understands animals loves them and
there's nobody that loves animals more
than this guy and uh I can attest to
that this has been awesome uh Ryan
wasn't this cool this is great it was
just we never hear about we I just
learned so much I think people are gonna
really you know the last thing I want to
end with this is just a quick story ah
yeah I just want to ask you what you
remember about working with Pacino or
you remember meeting him when you
trained his dog and and don't you have
something that you're gonna send me and
maybe we can post it I am going to send
you a canceled check receipt from Al
Pacino
um this is what I remember the first
time I met opportunity you know I had to
meet a driver in Manhattan had to get
into his car to drive me to The
Brownstone that Pacino was living in so
I go upstairs and I walk in the room
there's Al Pacino
David Mamet do I have that right and
Elliott Gould
and they're playing Atari baseball
and I'm here to train the dog they were
in the other room playing baseball I'm
saying hello guy and you got to learn
how to do this I'm not coming over every
day to train your dog and so they said
why don't you join us and play some
baseball with us we need a fourth that
was the first time I met him after that
he got stoned with him I didn't get
stolen but that way after that after
that he had another house in Westchester
County I went there working with his
dogs lucky and Susie and that's the
point where he was getting ready to do
Scarface
so when I was in the house I was
training the dog he was another room
right here you [__] cockroach all
these different things he was practicing
but then the funny part about it was he
came he grew up in an Italian
neighborhood Italians and Jews very
similar and all they kept saying yo Juan
you want a sandwich hungry you want to
sail
nice guy really nice guy wow really nice
guy everyone every one of the
celebrities I worked with I'm trying to
think they had to be one [__]
one guy you're just like man he wasn't
very nice I'm sure you there was a
couple you won't say that they kind of
became an [__] one was a news anchor
that kind of became sort of an [__]
they were cool and once they got a
little popularity they became kind of
like huh yeah I could I could give you a
long by the way one quick mention
The Mickey Mouse Club don't forget that
I was the creature keeper on the new
Mickey Mouse Club for years wow for
years and so now I can't look at those
girls anymore because I knew them when
they were little so I can't look at them
anymore as folks who are they who are
they now imagine their names but they're
very famous very very famous and so I
would go to Orlando and do the Mickey
Mouse Club as the creature keeper I got
some videos of that someday when you
come over the house actually it's pretty
it's pretty funny and I had to do why
because we like you the whole Mickey
Mouse thing it's pretty funny Jesus
this has been awesome I love you I adore
you thank you for being here this is
amazing this is amazing my pleasure
well you know I haven't had a family
member on
so that was
it was cool man I just I always wanted
him to come on the podcast but I'm not I
wasn't sure if he wanted to come on or
you know there wasn't he wasn't going
hey I'll do your podcast he wasn't doing
that I think because he's very humble
and but when I go hey you want to do it
he's like sure like he's a former radio
guy he's a former radio guy he's still
ready to go he has the pet show he has
the pet show and you can watch that
every week go to Warren Eckstein
Eckstein I always say Eckstein yeah it's
X dime or next time I think people say
xdean but that's the baseball player
David Eckstein that's right right that's
right I think that's right Warren I love
you uh it was an honor to have you on
the podcast
and uh keeping uh awesome Denise
I love you
that's Anthony's
she's amazing she keeps him in line
without Dan Denise what would we have
we'd have a very incorrigible
um is it uncorrigible
incorrigible that's right I haven't said
it in a while so I was questioning it I
always ask you for a word is this right
I say my brother does that to me a lot
is that the right word I'm like just say
it if it's not people will go he's an
idiot
um thank you uh everybody knows where to
go what to do spread the word thank you
for uh being here let's talk about my
top tier patrons
these are the folks that um just go
above and beyond and really support the
podcast and without them I couldn't do
it I will write you a message after you
join if you want to join patreon.com
inside of you here are the top tiers I
didn't bring water but oh well
Nancy D Leah ass little
Lisa you Gene and you you
Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert
Jason W Sophie and Raj see Joshua D
Jennifer L N correct Stacy L Jamal B no
F Janelle B correct Mike E El Don El Dan
really yeah really you know we love you
Dan
I love that poem they tell you that he
wrote a poem for me and me and dancing
about for Sun spin about your albums and
our in life and it was beautiful so what
I did
was Dave Rhymes son's been with unhinged
no he's a really good writer he's smart
he's a lawyer he's just he's just a good
dude and you know
um
so
I
hold on let's see so he sent Rob the uh
the poem and I put this over and I
narrated it for him I'm just gonna give
you a little bit
[Music]
when the sun spins
nothing as Eternal as The Melody of the
richest ballads that call to me as
soothing as the song that sets you free
spins for him you and me
soothing is the beat that melts the
heart of so many lyrical works of art
The Sun Shines away the shadows as the
spin changes perspective
of harsh Life Lessons Learned respected
anyway well isn't that something yeah so
I thought it was really cool so thank
you Dan put that over stock footage of
some of the sunsets yeah yeah
99 more Santiago AMS Chad W Lee and P
Maya P Leanne P Maya p
yeah for God's sakes
Maddie
Maddie Sipe yeah
Belinda and Dave
forgotten Dave Hall he's got his English
now and hey Michael it's really nice to
see he's got a really nice voice he's a
very English and very quiet very
reserved right yeah I like Dave he's
like yeah Michael I really like the um
episode where you shut up and I'll even
say that Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T
Tom and Talia M Betsy D Chad Boone I own
Luther Corp he
Angel M ran and C Cory K devnix and
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey M
Eugene and Leah Corey Heather L Jake B
Angela F Mill s Orlando C Caroline R
Christine s
Eric eight Shane R Andrew M Tim L Amanda
R gen B Kevin e Stephanie K jorel GM and
J Leanne J Hey Joe
hey can you grab my water I think it's
on the table or whatever
oh thanks man I need a drink of water I
can hear myself going
it's nothing worse than hearing that I
never want to be that guy I I had it on
an interview once early on and the
person was like yeah
um I was like oh God
hmm
I actually told her to get water
in a nice way
Luna R Mike F Stone H Brian L Katie B
Aaron R Kendall L Meredith I Sarah C
Cara C Cara
Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P Des Estevan G
Kaylee J Brian a Ashley f
Al V
I believe it's Al V Mary and Louise L
Romeo B Veronica Q the s
the S also known as LS in Spanish Chris
D and gen T couldn't do this without you
guys thank you for supporting the
podcast I'll send you a message when you
join patreon.com inside of you this has
been a real treat thank you Warren Uncle
Warren for being on the podcast Ryan
thanks for being here yeah of course and
um you like my uncle didn't you I loved
it it was great it was fun right I'm
gonna tell my sister to listen to it
because she has a dog who uh
could use some
some tips really yeah she should listen
to the pet show he knows what he's doing
yeah
I love that dog though it's my nephew
even though he's a little nuts Reggie
like my dog Charlie he's nuts
they're nuts but we love him he's a pup
he's a pub adorable it's all right from
the Hollywood Hills in California I'm
Michael Rosenbaum I'm Miranda
quiet reserve a little wave of the
camera we love you guys thank you so
much and always Ryan
uh oh uh be good to yourself be good
yourself of course do it damn it all
right we'll see you next week
[Music]